San Francisco California now plans to
fight its homelessness epidemic with
free parking the city is offering a safe
parking lot for dozens of people living
out of their cars but it is the same
city that already gives out free
syringes all right so are these ideas
working Michael Knoll so so the Michael
Nolt show joins us now to talk about
this there's two ways you can go about
it you either get tough on it or you can
go easier on people what do you think of
this plan guess which way San Francisco
is going to go unfortunately my own city
of Los Angeles isn't very far behind San
Francisco in this regard that I'm
actually just shocked that the
politicians in San Francisco think that
there's this abundance of parking spaces
that they're going to give out as safe
shelter I can never find parking when
I'm in San Francisco and of course
there's no such thing as a safe parking
lot to live in parking lots are meant
for parking your car and getting out of
your car every irresponsible teenager
every frugal traveler has dozed off for
a few hours in his car but cars are for
driving or not for living in nobody has
a right to live on the street this is
this is unsafe this is a social band-aid
for morally myopic and cowardly
politicians who don't want to deal with
the real problems of homelessness which
are mental illness their addiction and
they're not enforcing the laws so let's
take a look at some numbers here because
as you'll see a little over a third of
San Francisco's homeless people actually
live in vehicles and then let's go to
our next graphic which explains a little
bit about this safe parking program and
as you can see it's 30 spots available
people must come recommended by the San
Francisco homeless outreach team
bathroom and showers are provided
parking only for 90 days at a time they
are going to be capping that and they
will also be providing services and
managers to help the homeless find other
housing options including long-term
housing so I mean you look at everything
that they are I guess in theory
attempting to do here especially in the
outreach by attempting to provide
longer-term housing solutions is that
going in the right direction the key
word is in theory how have these San
Francisco politicians done at tackling
homelessness the last two years since
2017 homelessness is up 30% in
francisco that's three zero and it's
because they're getting the program
totally backwards they're getting the
problem totally backwards they think
that because there's a surge in
homelessness they need to relax the
enforcement of their laws but actually
relaxing the enforcement of the laws is
causing more of a surge in homelessness
you see a similar situation in san
francisco with the needle exchanges they
have this epidemic of drug use on the
streets of san francisco so they say hey
i know what we'll do we'll give out free
syringes to homeless people what could
go wrong well drug use has skyrocketed
crime has skyrocketed and they collect
very few of the needles they only
collect about I don't know sixty
sixty-two percent so you've got forty
percent of the needles all over the
street with the the risk of spreading
disease spreading infection and reducing
the quality of life for every single
person in San Francisco including the
homeless people there is no compassion
to this policy it is it is just another
way of ignoring the problem and ignoring
the people living on the street it's
essentially the government saying if you
were okay with you doing heroin that's
fine I mean it's it's basically saying
it's fine we don't mind and as you see
here nearly 60 million syringes 58
million syringes have been given out by
the city of San Francisco just in 2018
that is a tremendous amount another
problem Michael is is the the cost of
living in California is so high well
this problem continued until they get
some kind of control on that until
people can afford housing I think the
bigger issue then the cost of living is
that people aren't enforcing the law you
know under Rudy Giuliani in New York the
cost of living was very high and yet
homelessness and crime dropped
precipitously and the reason for that is
he took a hard line and he understood
that living on the street is a
dysfunctional act that harms the
individual and at harm society nobody
benefits from it the issue here isn't
that we need more rent control laws in
San Francisco look at what that's done
to housing in that city already what you
need is more police on the street you
need to empower them to do their job and
you need politicians to enforce the laws